merci la parole est à monsieur jacques
legendre pour le groupe union pour un
mouvement populaire
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre des affaires étrangères
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues au
printemps 2013 le régime du général
bozizé président de la république
centrafricaine s'est effondrée sous les
coups d'une rébellion dit c'est lé cas
bangui la capitale a été pillé ainsi que
les principales villes de province les
morts les viols ont été nombreux
la communauté internationale n'a guère
réagi à cette situation se limitant à
offrir son soutien à un premier ministre
sans réelle autorité sur les forces de
la série k quand à la france qui
maintient des soldats à l'aéroport de
bangui elle n'a pas voulu s'impliquer a
priori dans ce conflit interne et on
peut le comprendre et elle c'est l'unité
à assurer la sécurité de ses
ressortissants
mais peut-on se contenter de cette
situation attentiste
je ne le crois pas l'état centrafricain
a implosé il ne contrôle plus son
territoire vers lequel convergent des
pillards venus du tchad du soudan en
partie est du darfour d'ailleurs de
caractère religieux se produisent dans
un pays jusqu'ici tolérant la disette
menace car les paysans n'ose plus
ensemencé leurs champs dans la bouche où
la sécurité n'est pas assurée ne nous y
trompons pas si la communauté
internationale continue à se
désintéresser de ce drame un territoire
de six cent mille kilomètres carrés
peuplé de 4 millions et demi d'habitants
frontalier de pays fragiles la
république démocratique du congo le sud
soudan peut devenir à son tour le
sanctuaire de tous les trafics et de
tous les fanatismes
je connais bien la rca où j'ai enseigné
jadis en tant que coopérant le peuple
centrafricain a toujours attendu
beaucoup de la france est peut-être trop
d'ailleurs mais il est francophile et
nous avons un devoir d' aide à son égard
je rappellerai que ce pays
a été un des premiers a rallié la france
libre jadis cette fois il nous demande
de l'aider à rétablir son état a
retrouvé la paix à choisir librement par
des élections loyal ses dirigeants et
son destin bien évidemment cette mission
ne peut pas être celle de la france
seule il faut un mandat de l'onu faut
agir avec l'union africaine mais il y à
une urgence monsieur le ministre quel
concours la france entend elle apporté
au retour de la paix en république
centrafricaine
merci monsieur legendre la parole et à
monsieur laurent fabius
cher monsieur légende il ne vous a pas
échappé qu'à l'assemblée générale des
nations unies le président la république
française dans le court propos qu'il a
tenus devant l'ensemble des chefs d'état
et gouvernement
à
centrer l'essentiel de son discours sur
la république centrafricaine et nous a
pas non plus échapper que dimanche
dernier le ministre des affaires
étrangères du gouvernement français en
l'occurrence moi même
accompagné de la commissaire européenne
chargée des questions humanitaires s'est
rendu en république centrafricaine à
bangui
pour
aborder les sujets que vous avez abordé
un public centrafricaine
ces trois initiales sont versés par le
problème c'est que le a aujourd'hui ça
veut dire abandon
l'abandon c'est un pays
de 4 millions huit cent mille habitants
dont 10% de la population aujourd'hui
est déplacé une mortalité infantile
de plus de 10%
une capitale bangui où le sécurité plus
ou moins assurée par ce qu'il y a les
troupes françaises et le reste du pays
ravagé par des bandes armées
personne ne s'intéressait à ce sujet et
se trouve que la france parce que c'est
sa mission a décidé de lancer la larme
sur
ce territoire qui comme son nom
l'indiqué est au centre de l'afrique est
une réflexion de bon sens
est nécessaire on ne peut pas prétendre
porter attention à l'afrique continent
d'avenir si on ne porte pas attention et
appui au centre de l'afrique qui
s'appelle la république centrafricaine
le sujet si on veut le schématiser
c'est au moins trois séries de
préoccupation d'abord la sécurité
dans les provinces
situation effrayante
vous l'avez des great en quelques mots
et pour la première fois dans l'histoire
de la centrafrique des conflits d'ordre
religieux entre les chrétiens qui sont
majoritaires et les musulmans
j'ai rencontré dimanche dernier les
chefs des trois principales religions
la foi catholique protestant et
musulmane eux sont totalement opposés à
ces oppositions internes mais il l'est
constate il les condamne ils les
déplorant et puis se greffent là dessus
là c'est les cas qui a été dissoute par
le chef d'état de la transition comme on
dit chef d'état qui n'est pas reconnue
par la communauté internationale
monsieur d'auto dia et la cdca dont les
sols ne sont pas payés pas plus que
celle des fonctionnaires depuis quatre
mois pour une part va revenir à la vie
civile pour une part doit être intégré
dans l'armée vous voyez les problèmes
que cela peut poser est donc les quatre
pays limitrophes c'est à dire
essentiellement le tchad le congo
cameroun gabon ont envoyé des troupes
aujourd'hui elles sont de 1100 elles
vont monter à 3500 au sein d'une force
qu'on appelle la miss k la france
elle-même assure ce place 410 hommes
elle envisage d'augmenter son contingent
si nécessaire et nous avons obtenu
monsieur legendre vous n'avez pas eu le
temps de le rappeler une résolution du
conseil de sécurité des nations unies
nous la france à l'unanimité qui fait
obligation au secrétaire-général 30
jours de présenter un rapport il y aura
une deuxième résolution qui donnera
mandat à cette force d'intervenir
davantage ainsi qu'à la france puis une
troisième résolution au printemps plus
tard pour envisager peut-être ce qu'on
appelle une opération de maintien de la
paix donc sécurité numéro un et quatre
pays agissant au nom de la communauté
des états de l'afrique centrale en
liaison avec tuner afrique est plus la
france humanitaire la situation est
celle que je vous ai écrit tel est
abominable et l'europe france communauté
internationale conférence des donateurs
doit permettre d'avancer et puis le
problème politique des élections doivent
avoir lieu au plus tard en février 2015
mais il n'ya plus d'état civil et avant
2015 il faudra qu'il y ait un référendum
pour accepter la constitution et il faut
donc une montée en régime démocratique
alors que les deux principaux
responsables se doter dia et son premier
ministre n'ont pas le droit de se
présenter à ces élections et m'ont
confirmé devant les représentants de la
chose unique qui ne le ferai pas bref
tout est à faire nous avons discuté avec
le président d'afrique du sud avec
madame zuma a au nom de l'union
africaine avec les quatre pays
limitrophes que je tiens étroitement au
courant la france fera son devoir bref
ce qui est notre position sans nous
substituer aux africains sans nous
substituer aux africains d'attirer
l'attention internationale sur ce
conflit qui peut être gravissimes d'agir
en mobilisant à la fois l'europe la
communauté internationale l'ensemble de
l'afrique est d'apporter à nos amis
africains le soutien qu'ils méritent
bref ce que j'ai dit aux centrafricains
comme je vous le dit monsieur le
sénateur
la france ne laissera pas tomber la
république centrafricaine
merci monsieur le ministre